one question I
have I don't know about you but for me
unlike with the Soviet
Union and I know I was born there but
even outside of that the cultural
Gap the the the loss in Translation the
communication gap between China and the
United States seems to be much greater
than that of what was the former Soviet
Union and the United States
I see two cultures intermingling and
communicating as one of the ways to
deescalate future
conflict it's an interesting question I
mean it at a sort of an abstract
theoretical level my argument is that
great Powers Act according to realist
dictates and they understand those
realist dictates and uh that can lead to
cooperation or it can lead to to uh War
uh it depends U I would say just in the
case of the Soviets a lot of people
describe the Cold War as an ideological
competition above all else it's was
communism
versus liberal democracy or communism
versus liberal capitalism whatever uh I
actually don't believe that I I believe
the Soviets were uh realists to the
court
uh I believe Stalin was a realist par
Excellence uh and that ideology did not
matter much in Stalin's foreign policy
and I believe if you look at Soviet
foreign policy uh after World War II you
know throughout the Cold War they were
realists to the core uh and uh and I
think in those days the Americans were
realists right uh a lot of liberal
ideology floating around out there but
the Americans were realists and I think
one of the reasons you avoided uh a
shooting match between the United States
and the Soviet Union from 47 to uh
89 uh was because both sides I think uh
understood basic balance of power
logic us China competition is somewhat
different first of all the Chinese are
realist to the core uh I've spent a lot
of time in China I basically have rock
and roll I'm basically a rock and roll
star in China
uh the Chinese you're kind of a big deal
in China I love it the Chinese are my
kind of people yeah they're realists
right they speak my language yeah it's
the United States that is not very
realist American leaders uh have a very
powerful liberal bent and tend not to
see the world in realist terms I Believe
by the way just going back to our
discussion of NATO expansion I think our
inability to understand that NATO
expansion was anathema to the Soviet to
the Russians was doing large part to the
fact that we just during the unipolar
moment didn't think of international
politics from a realist perspective and
didn't respect anyone who thought about
International politics from a realist
perspective if those various American
administrations starting with the
Clinton administration had put their
realest hat on they would have
understood that NATO expansion into
Ukraine was not a good idea but we had
this thoroughly liberal view of the
world that dominated our thinking and
it's gone away somewhat since we've
moved into multipolarity but not
completely and uh this makes me a little
nervous right to pick up on your point I
mean the United States is thinking about
the world in ways that are somewhat
different than the Chinese Who real as
par exellence so that's fascinating so
the Chinese are
pragmatic uh about thinking of the world
and
um as a competition of military Powers
all the ways in which he described the
realist perspective so that I mean
that's a that's a that's a hopeful thing
right
if uh we can achieve stability and a
balance of powers through that military
competition yeah I I actually think
that's right I think if the United
States just let me talk a little bit
about the United States to get out the
issue you're raising if the United
States pursues a smart containment
strategy mhm given what you just said
and I said about the Chinese I think we
will avoid war the problem with the
Americans is it's not just the
liberalism it's the possibility that we
will pursue a rollback
policy in other words during the Cold
War uh we pursued containment it was
whenever anybody talked about American
Grand strategy towards the Soviet Union
was Containment containment containment
we now know from the his hisorical
record that the United States was not
only pursuing containment it was
pursuing roll back we were trying to
roll back Soviet power to put it bluntly
we were trying to wreck the Soviet Union
okay and I would not be surprised moving
forward with regard to China if the
United States pursues a serious roll
back
policy
I